CBS Evening News anchor and managing
editor Noor O'Donnell spoke exclusively
with for the seven Democratic House
impeachment managers she talked with
Intelligence Committee Chairman Adam
Schiff and Representatives Val Demings
Lofgren and Jason grow nor asked how
they will make their case for the
president's removal and why they
disagree with his argument that abuse of
power is not a crime the president
United States has privileges and powers
that no other person has so the abuse of
those very unique powers and privileges
is exactly what the framers had in mind
when they drafted the impeachment
procedures let me ask you about the
question of witnesses presumably you
would want to call john bolton but are
you prepared then for who the
republicans want to call as witnesses
would that be fair it's really fair for
the president and his team to be able to
call witnesses that can provide material
information on the charges it would not
be appropriate for the president to seek
to call witnesses merely to try to
perpetuate the same smear campaign that
was foiled when his plot was discovered
hunter Biden for example can't tell us
anything about whether the president
withheld military aid whether he
withheld that aid to coerce Ukraine to
conduct political investigations or why
he wouldn't meet with the president of
Ukraine the only purpose in putting him
on their list is they wish to trade
material witnesses like mr. Bolton and
Mulvaney and others for immaterial ones
that will allow them to continue to
attack a political opponent that's an
illegitimate abuse of the trial and the
Chief Justice who may have an
opportunity to rule on materiality of
witnesses as well as the senator should
not prevent that kind of abuse
you